hello this is Robert Scoble and I'm
giving you my thoughts on the Davos
question which is how do you improve the
world on one one thing I'm studying here
where I'll at Davos is how to improve
the water quality around the world
because there's billions of people who
don't have the clean water that I do to
drink every day on or use in their
fields or use you know to take a bath in
on and it if you don't have clean water
everything else doesn't quite measure up
right doesn't matter that you have a
cell phone or a computer if you don't
have to water doesn't matter that you
have food drink if you don't get clean
water you're going to be too sick to eat
food or get on the fields and work where
I hang out with your family so if
there's one thing that I I think we
could do to improve the world it's I
think about how to make clean water
there's some innovations here that I've
heard about so far they're pre
interesting one guy built a tricycle
that while you drive it around or ride
it around it's actually filtering water
for your family's use that's pretty
interesting famous that's it from Davos